hallo freunde ich bin guter hoffnung mit
gott geredet darum dass er durch ko ich
bin gerade auf der höri poppig hallo
hallo ich meine lieben freunde ich werde
direkt angegriffen von ihm zum toben
zombie habe ich nicht so herzlich
willkommen zurück die christmas kraft
zusammen mit dem hd hallo hallo
gestorbenen letzten folge zwei mal und
ich werde dich heute töten
nowak riet man ihm mehrere böse an ihren
tod so gemeint er wird mich diese folge
töten ich habe die letzte folge getötet
aber nur wenn ich mein haus werfen im
ersteren fläche er hat mich angegriffen
ich habe ihn getötet
du sagst ja nicht alle koordinaten durch
button muss selber wissen
wir leben jetzt im krieg bombe hat hier
gemeinsame wir leben jetzt in getrennten
lagern ich dachte ich dass zwischen den
regionen
das war dein vorschlagen der mann zu
hören kriegt das artet jetzt voll
auslasten das projekt hier und heute
kommt man halt so alles aber bei mir ist
es so dass ich wollte keinen krieg und
der kombi hat er damals griff die stimme
ich damals zu wenn ihr unbedingt krieg
will dann hat meinte der so im zimmer
von 65 von fünf runter und er boxt mich
und ich schieß mit dem bogen und er ist
einfach gestorben und die pure wahrheit
leute da hat man schon gesehen
man ist einfach nicht sagen dass ich auf
jeden fall hier der bar bin im projekt
ja natürlich aber das wird sich heute
ändern das blatt denn du wirst heute
nicht nur einmal sterben du wirst gleich
drei mal sterben in dieser folge ist
dass der einst so ein bisschen zu viel
gesoffen oder nein
mach dich auf etwas gefasst wollen wir
noch gott schlafengehen und rüsten will
ich nicht schade
ich verwahre mich auch schon wieder 1000
mal das hat gar nicht wie ich mein haus
überhaupt bauen möchte soll
na ja doch das schön
ich finde das einfach nur geil
du gehst doch bestimmt auch gerade mit
deiner ganz mit bogen mit schwert und so
weiter ein haus bauen oder wenn man muss
ja mittlerweile wirklich immer darauf
gefasst sein dass er mittlerweile hier
auch im krieg leben er ja eben das ist
alles sehr spannend da muss man
selbstverständlich auch immer so ein
bisschen rücksicht geben weiß natürlich
auch direkt sein könnte das auf einer
hinter dir stehen
ja natürlich es kann immer mal passieren
richtig freue mich auch was er gerade
macht zum beispiel weil wir es nicht
mehr ich bin auf der suche nach nahrung
um ehrlich zu sein ich bin ich einfach
umgeräumt aussagen kommen wir teilen
unser brot und heute ist als nur im
krieg genannt kommt nicht rein
frag mich jetzt natürlich schon mal der
gome ist oder wo seine partei hat es
etwas stehen von deiner base oder noch
ja ja ich hab schon die wende ein wenig
an gezeichnet aber noch nicht
hochgezogen
also man man würde erkennen wenn man
daran vorbeiläuft als dass meine bude
ist dann suchen wir jetzt mal bei
missbrauchen
ich gebe mir nach hochgekriegt nichts
deshalb stellt jetzt wird sie läuft ja
auch er gar nix oben wer kein kein tier
richtig laut wikileaks rum alter das ist
mir auch schon aufgefallen muss 1000
blöcke laufen damit sie dazu den ersten
die ihren mann komme hinkomme
bum bum bum bum und schöne inseln ich
sehe auch gerade da hinten ist ihr
anderes holz
das ist schön aber macht doch dass du
das wirklich anderes holz nur bringen
wir mal 56 mit bringen scheißhaufen mit
alter macht wir leben im krieg kommen
nach der nicht vergessen wird wer wollte
hier der krieg du wolltest den krieg
überschlägig ich bin hier der natürlich
hier soziales ja denn mama wollte lieber
alt sich direkt ein schwert kräften
wurde nach dem tod nähe das nicht tun
doch nicht jeder außer gomez aber
erstmal intern offen dessen sind hier
gern richtig laufe jetzt schon eine
halbe ewigkeit aber finde einfach gar
kein tier hatte ich liebe das mit einer
schere blättert man halt einfach nur
drücken und direkt alles weg okay sie
ist kaputt aber jetzt hab ich so was von
46 gleich wenn ich mir das jetzt alles
einsammeln damit mein haus schön
aussehen und sicher sein
ich habe ich durch die blätter netto
erhält eine starke verteidigung auf
jeden fall denke ich auch hoch wenn der
kommende ankommt dann habe ich ihr
flower power blätter sind doch
eigentlich eine stabile wand weil ich
meine abfackeln davon nicht und abbauen
kann man mit der schere schnell die
blätter und auch recht viele hey du
darfst nicht anna ja ich meine jetzt
noch im vergleich mit holz wenn du
meinen erstmal zehn bäume fällen müsste
es damit überhaupt das holz für eine
wende als das ist schon das dauert
erheblich länger als wenn du meine
dingen blätter nimmst dir einfach mit
der schere ab macht vom baum innerhalb
von ein paar sekunden und dann gemeinsam
sind jetzt auch nicht so schön aus
natürlich würde sagen dass jedes haus
also das heißt dass die häuser die wir
bauen
mindestens einen eingang haben muss wo
der andere rein darf den mann nicht zu
bauen darf dass es zu einer
konfrontation mehr oder weniger kommen
muss
okay okay das ist interessant dass der
jetzt witzig ihn würde ich hier viel
lieber hinziehen ihr gefällt zeigen wie
viel schöner ist ein kleiner see aber
egal ich muss mich jetzt natürlich hier
auf den krieg dann einstellen
ich frag mich mal wieder kommen ist die
welt der verspielte lässig will echt am
arsch der welt
ich habe keine nahrung band ich ich bin
hier auf der nahrungssuche natürlichkeit
im oder nahrung an wenn ich nicht
sprinten kann genau so blöd bin ich das
auch für mich ich könnte schwören com
ist die irgendwo in der nähe niemals
wenn du hier bist wo ich gerade bin
dann bist da war weit gelaufen aber so
richtig weit also ich glaube niemals das
finde ich in meiner nähe ist
mindestens zwei blöcke von mir weg
mindestens sondern das nix man natürlich
ist er richtig viel zunächst ich bin in
einer folge 2000 blöcken war minuten
gegangen
oktober ein f3 gericht 400.000 bürki
weit weg auf die auf die z koordinate
wie hoch dieser hochschnellt 60 65 70 75
80 das nicht so mein haus wird aber
richtig richtig geil ich glaube das tut
richtig schön so was könnte ich hier
wochen ein strahlemann
da kommt noch mal hat er jedes recht auf
kein tier war traurig bestimmt gerade
lauern im chat kill kill all damit alle
regler wir gar nicht ich glaube das geht
nicht
wörtlich oder auch ließ
neben schließt den geile ausfindig
sowohl das wird ein schönes
dekorationsstück meines hauses die
schönen blätter einrichtung sendung hier
mit konkreter & gamble haben wir einen
wunderschönen kürbis den könnt ihr euch
hier neben den eingang immer wunderbar
ein leichter windhauch blätter rüber
nein das ist wissen sie wirklich voll
cool aus was ich irgendwie weiß nicht
hat zwar keine idee dass es mir nur
irgendwie grab so eingefallen aber
irgendwann kam ich bald mal jedoch
interessant und ich glaube auch wenn du
noch mal ankommen wilson eine komische
revanche da haben willst du willst ja
diese folgen drei mal töten
ja ohne darum geht dass dich auch mal du
hast gesagt haben wenn es nicht machst
du irgendwas so vereinbart wenn es nicht
schaffst dennoch nicht schafft muss ich
auch mal muss auch erstmal wieder zurück
lauf ich bin wirklich weit weg bissig
wird zu hause wenn das dauert ewigkeiten
wann ich weiß nicht oder solche noch so
einen kleinen ich habe das irgendwie
alles ein bisschen zu klein gebaut finde
ich ja ich habe eine idee wo ja was denn
auch gar nix die darf ich das kann
wirklich nichts sagen
ich habe eine idee ich glaube ich weiß
wie ich das jetzt mache ich glaube ich
mache das laufen kannst du neugierig ja
jetzt reißt dich auch noch sprüche ich
reiße die ultra sprüche hat noch keiner
gehört und in wirklichkeit steht der
wieder
ja ja träum weiter ich jetzt noch tiere
finde da bist du tot
ok
einverstanden kommen du bist ein
bisschen zu übermütig diese folge
falscher stolz aber irgendwie doof nicht
bereit mich gerade gar nicht vorher nie
auf dem krieg ich auch nicht wirklich
ich laufe einfach nur um versuchen das
schwein und und kühl garantieren
einfachen spiegel komme boah gegeben
haben wir alle gelacht wie heute kann
ich ihm gegeben da war war so hart dass
sport aber findet ihr gomez witze besser
oder meine was für die frage natürlich
den us logisch soweit ich weiss ich hier
noch vertrauen
na gut ich trainer wieder um ich finde
doch keine nahrung mehr
das ist doch echt unglaublich was geht
gar nichts ich bin jetzt echt ein
bisschen niedergeschlagen dadurch und
wenn ich jetzt mein mann du riechst du
hast eh irgendwann irgendwie du hast
schon was gefunden das bestimmt auch
schon diamanten
ja genau mal eben fünf minuten heißt
kontrast oder was denn video macht
ich schwöre dir wenn ich das nächste
voll gemacht dass ich es geht ich wette
mit ihr es geht ok wette gilt
wir kriegen katastrophen
doch ich mache das einfach persönlich
für mich angreift ich antrete
so warte wie bräuchten jetzt mein haus
heran
was ist das nicht ein bisschen klein jo
ich auch dass vielleicht ein bisschen
klein gemacht
altershalber mega klein ja ich bin schön
kann man aus zuckerrohr irgendwie
nahrung machen
damit kann man papier machen man kann
damit bücher dadurch ja auch machen aber
ich glaube nicht ich mache das auch
nicht hier raus ich mach das aus dem
anderen holz ich hab so schöne ideen für
meinen häusler
das ist richtig schön da freue ich mich
drüber ich bin gespannt was da gerade
entsteht
ich meine ich habe auch nicht wirklich
angefangen bei mir kommt aber auch noch
irgendwann wenn ich mal nahrung habe ich
wette mit dir du dich ich könnte einfach
schwören dass jetzt irgendwo im base
gemacht ist nix die ganze zeit dass du
dich nicht sehen oder irgendwie sowas da
denke ich dass du so schlau bist du das
machst das auf solche ideen kommt ohne
nahrung ist das ist immer das beste oder
nahrung mit wieder erwähnen dass du oft
mit der nahrung
ja es ist einfach so man ich lauf hier
nur geradeaus und denker diese blöde
nahrung halten nach grün ausschau das
nervt einfach nur nicht weiß was ich
brauche ist 1000-mal alter
ich glaube ich sollte mich echt mal ein
bisschen vorbereiten wir sind
tintenfische habe dir noch schnee ja
echt immer noch mal ich weiß aus seinem
video hat ja bei dir auch geschneit und
ach so draußen ich dachte man es ist
minecraft microfit die neue realität
bei uns liegt kein schnee aber
ich weiter bei einem kumpel und da lag
schnee ein bisschen ganz klein bisschen
weg wunderbar da lag schnee aber ich
möchte auch schnee was auch direkt eine
schneeballschlacht gemacht aber jetzt wo
ich so viel schneeballschlacht auf dem
sektor pro oder so dass das da kommt
vielleicht was bei mir ja jetzt um das
leben das du hast jetzt ihr verrät so
anders na ja richtig geile idee auch
schon mit re wie schon vor einer woche
und da kommt auf jeden fall verraten was
wird wenn es so wird wie wir uns das
denken damit es richtig richtig gut das
kommt dann wahrscheinlich irgendwann so
um silvester herum schneeballschlacht
nein aber wir haben richtig gute idee
aber ich finde mein haus ist das heißt
ich mache mit conny ich glaub ich wer
sagt denn dass in köln ist das heißt es
weiter
damit direkt ja ich komme auch nach köln
kommt irgendwie immer köln wenn meine
enkel von treffen also spricht dann
jetzt also weil alle möglichen spaß in
köln wohin
davon möchte unbedingt ein foto davon
machen das ist richtig schön mein haus
ich habe schon mal schafe gefunden das
ist schon mal gar nicht schlecht aber im
ernst eine schneeballschlacht bestimmt
30 oder also schlitten verhandelt na ja
das sind ein paar sachen sind auch echt
mega cool
genauso wie ich es aber ich habe auf
jeden fall richtig geile sachen geplant
auf jeden fall machen ach so ich muss
doch ganz kurz hier für den links führen
kontakt mache ich jetzt immer so täglich
so eine zusammenfassung was ich das
mache dann stand es dann zusammen passt
seinem video gesehen ist es jetzt mal
eben während der aufnahmen machen dann
seid ihr so aufnahmesession man hört
verkommen jetzt gerade dann zwar nicht
aber wie man hört mich mit ihm reden
hier seht ihr dass mein handy warum hört
man welchen hallo freunde ich bin euer
häftling mitgeredet krumm dass er ihr
gleich erwartet
ich bin ihm auf der höri was ich da tue
damit ich hallo und jetzt habe ich ein
bisschen dumm gelaufen wir dass meine
tolle tolle band und ja ich bin grad mit
goal.com beim aufnehmen christmas kraft
und sonst geht der zweiten programm
heute dienstag einfach mal so einen
ausschnitt vom kontakt so mittendrin
aufgenommen er konnte so eine richtige
spaten conny ja was hörst du mich warum
hörst du mich ich dachte du hast mich
nicht ich habe diese zeit gehört ich
hatte die kopfhörer drin du meintest
doch auch die leute ja die leute kommen
ich verstehe die leute können nicht in
welcher die kopfhörer denn am 1 und die
folge einfach eigentlich schon wieder
vorbei aber ich möchte einen baum fällen
einbauen möchte ich noch voll nehmen
dass eine spinne
wie macht man sich nochmal enchantment
table war ich glaub ich habe jetzt ein
aus leder diamanten ob es viele
ich habe jetzt noch beck 2 auf meinem
dia schwert kommen du kannst du ich
komme jetzt noch ne du hast ja aber doch
nicht als option zaubert fisch hat als
ob du hast ich meine wo er sonst die
sonst in nothberg bekommen ich habe ein
buch grad gefunden
ja bestimmt da hab ich mir entweder
gebaut jaja wollen nicht bei dir zu
hause bist du doch auch gar nicht du
bist doch gerade gar nicht zu hause als
auch unterwegs den ende craft ist dein
schwert verzaubert ja genau woher weißt
du dass ich gar nicht zu hause
weil ich vielleicht bei dir bin jetzt
klar dass sie keine kisten ausrauben
darf nicht kaputt machen darf auch nicht
lover setzen
nix das ist ja block setzen wollen das
ist regelverstößen disqualifiziert
in der skiregion häuser auch rennen ach
komm wir seitens spaß wenn du das
gemacht hat dann war schalke aber ich
nicht ich würde jetzt extra alle tiere
in der umgebung nichts zu essen mehr
hatte ob die tiere hast doch richtig
viel licht viel geld investieren
suchend rumgelaufen das ist unglaublich
und du findest einfach welche genau ich
doof gerechtigkeit sich ungerecht
richtig auf die kacke also richtig man
leute ist das fragwürdig warum findet er
die folge seien wichtig weil eben freien
der werden heute kein thema das ist
einfach weil wir diesen krieg haben
unsere zeit in seinem krieg zustand sind
dass wir nicht über dem zueinander
diskutieren ja in der nächsten folge
wird das dann erstmal weitergehen
und dann wird bissig nahrung habe es
kommt mir das meisterschafts komme ich
in folge zu töten könnt ihr morgen
einfach mal vorbei gucken und sagen bis
jetzt ja jetzt ist es wenn ich so geil
und sonst würde ich sagen
die morgens am morgen wieder und wieder
rein bis zum nächsten mal
autor ein schirm